right joining us now from Washington
Republican Congressman Jim Jordan Ron de
Santos and the man we just quoted Matt
Gaetz congressman Jordan let me begin
with you do you know as I have heard
directly from people sarah has heard
catherine herridge is heard and others
and greg jarrett that in fact we have
rod Rosenstein threatening intimidating
to use the power of that office to go
after people in Congress and their
staffs trying to do their job I believe
it's happened Shawn I've talked to folks
who say it's happened who we're there so
if in fact this did take place which I
think it did this is the executive
branch threatening staffers of a
standing House committee trying to do
their job and get answers for the
American people this is as wrong as it
gets and the fundamental question it
raises is will the Speaker of this house
stand up and defend House Intelligence
Committee staffers and the best way to
do that in my judgment is to bring up
the resolution that the three of us
introduced and mr. meadows and others
introduced earlier today on the House
floor I agree with you where is the
speaker on that congressman Ron de
Santos Sean this conduct if true to me
is disqualifying he cannot be the Deputy
Attorney General if he's threatening
people who work in Congress simply
because we're doing our job to try to
get answers for the American people and
the arrogance of Rosenstein for months
and months to stone wall and stone wall
non-stop even basic answers to redact
information has just gotten to the
boiling point we in Congress need to act
I think his position there is untenable
what I am hearing
congressman gates is that one of the
reasons rod Rosenstein is doing a lot of
this is because there are specific
documents with specific days and
specific dates that may implicate him
have you heard the same thing
we have Shawn rod Racine Stein is
intractably conflicted in this
investigation and as brave Patriots like
Kosh Patel work hard for the Congress to
expose the corruption in the bias then
they're threatened by rod Rosenstein
this is outrageous
Hospital was in my office concerned for
the fact that he as a staff member was
his job and then somehow had a different
branch of government bringing these
threats upon him so I look I'm sick and
tired of rod Rosen Stein's games I think
we need to do with Pete Rosenstein he
won't turn over documents he signed a
FISA renewal against the President of
the United States and frankly if we
don't step up and defend our institution
then what good is the Congress anyway
okay and and he has this temper which I
don't know if all of all of you heard
about it because you're old can you
shake your head because I've heard about
it and even you know I think chairman
newness is being pretty nice because you
know I just assumed he didn't want to go
on the record but to use that power the
way we're talking about here here is
what I'm hearing congressman Jordan it's
either going to be the president demands
these documents or Congress has the
option of impeaching him and that
wouldn't require the speaker to step up
here but more importantly when do we get
the documents and how does Congress do
its job if they're being intimidated
that they're going to be the subject of
harassment and investigation as
retaliation for for Congress doing their
constitutional duty shelling you're
right there's there certain tools we
have in the toolbox they should all be
on our disposable to get the information
we constitutionally are entitled to get
to get answers for the American people
it's really that basic I think this week
there are kind of two fundamental
questions the first one is the report
comes out tomorrow from the inspector
general it will have people in there
that'll be cited for wrongdoing we'll
rod Rosenstein fire people who are cited
in the inspector general's report for
wrongdoing in the clinton investigation
and then the second fundamental question
is the one I raised before will the
Speaker of the House stand up and defend
people on house standing committees who
were threatened by the Department of
Justice and the best way to do that is
to bring up our resolution and if they
don't comply with the document request
in that resolution then to look for
exactly what Matt Gaetz talked about
contempt and impeachment are tools in
the toolbox that we may have to go to
and finally there's what Devin Oona said
which is the president can say release
the information so they can get answers
last question
exit question congressman De Santis and
gates we'll start with you congressman
de Santos is it would it be quicker
better for the country that the
president that he demand the documents
that Congress
has been obstructed from getting should
he demand that wouldn't that be the
faster path I think so Jim Jordan mark
Meadows and I sent him a letter a couple
weeks ago urging him to do that he has
the power and I think he should do it
the American people deserve the truth on
this hack Donald Trump has been treated
as poorly as anybody by some of these
jokers so he should definitely pull the
trigger on that totally agree shocker
totally agree absolutely you know look
guys this president has the power to
bring this thing home he can do it and
we're gonna stand behind him all right
thank you all for being with